[Musique]
nausicaa niaz main bonjour vous avez aux
candidats bonjour vous êtes candidat aux
municipales à saint joseph
vous allez conduire la liste ensemble
pour construire un joseph vous avez 48
ans et vous êtes chef d'entreprise c'est
cela alors vous avez déjà des
expériences électorales vous étiez lancé
il ya quelques années vous aviez fait 9
ans puis vous aviez quelque peu disparu
des radars
et puis vous étiez encore candide en
et pourquoi ce n'est pas candidat en
2014 pourquoi ce retour en 2020 et je
pense qu'il fallait mûrir continue le
travail de terrain
et puis les circonstances n'étaient pas
favorables 2014 qu'est ce qui vous
motive aujourd'hui alors aujourd'hui je
pense que après 18 années de gestion des
landes du maire actuel on a le voile a
dressé un bilan
il faut donner le temps au temps donné
aux hommes et les femmes les moyennes de
travailler à partir de leurs bilans dire
ce qui va par où ce qui pourrait être
amélioré pour construire demain alors
vous avez l'investiture et l'air les
républicains et vous êtes plusieurs
candidats de droite à saint joseph
alors nous sommes des candidats je vais
dit de la diversité de la droite puisque
la droite allait pluriel maintenant j'ai
été conseiller municipal de 95 à 2000
avec rim os ça fâche sur la liste saint
joseph à venir donc j'étais candidat en
2001 et en 2008
les autres candidats ont toute leur
légitimité pour représenter leur
dynamisme leur ambition et moi je pense
que c'est important de proposer l'offre
aux jo est fait pour que les 16000 et
les habitants de saint joseph et les
douze mille électeurs puissent faire le
choix le plus coupé avec le yan
monplaisir pourquoi vous n'êtes pas sur
sa liste pourquoi vous ne faites une
liste commune alors l'objectif pour nous
c'est d'être présent conseil municipal
je vous rappelle que mon ami yan
monplaisir en 2008 n'a pas siégé au
conseil municipal
je ne sais pas ce qu'il fera en 2020
sauf que nous nous croyons que le
militant que je suis les mini ton que
nous sommes nous devons accepter le
verdict des urnes et siéger si le devoir
de ce que nous devons faire lorsque des
électeurs des électrices des militants
des sympathisants sur se sacrifier
pendant des semaines pendant des mois
quel que soit le résultat qu'elle soit
relevé d'idées xoom nous siégerons très
bien ça veut dire que si un deuxième 12
vous êtes parce que c'est possible vous
puissiez vous retrouver s'il ya un
deuxième tour des élections a à saint
joseph
pour l'instant nous vous quoi nous
allons nous allons au premier tout pour
gagner il sortir devant mon seul
adversaire c'est à tana jeannoise une
fois et aux mallettes municipal si vous
êtes élu selon vous quelle serait la
priorité pour la municipalité joséphine
la priorité c'est d'abord une audite
pouvoir parce que je ne siège pas au
conseil municipal ne s'y joue pas pour
faire une idée pour savoir ce qu'il y à
allaiter you même si je pars je
participe comme d'autres citoyens lors
des conseils des séances de conseils
municipaux je participe donc on a aussi
les documents mais c'est important de
voir dans l'intérieur de faire un audit
ensuite rassembler les hommes et les
femmes de qui travaillait au sein de
cette municipalité
c'est à dire les employés municipaux
pour connaître les doléances
il y a trois syndicats à la baie à la
miss et joseph
plus les non syndiqués il est important
de les rencontrer pour connaître leur
lot vécu et aussi leurs attentes
et puis bien sûr la population les
conseils de quartier met en place tout
de suite les conseils de quartier pour
consolider le lien social
il faut aussi et c'est ça qui revient
souvent quand on rencontre les candidats
josefa se redynamiser le bourg s'est
redonné vie au bourg est tout à fait
puisque le bruit est abandonné il y à
cette nombre de commerciaux de communes
commerçants qui ont quitté leur activité
sans avoir eu la possibilité de
transmettre et donc c'est un beau à
l'abandon il est abandonné et c'est une
un beau fantôme il faut leur redonner
une âme et l'âme de saint joseph
c'est aussi ça passe par le bout et les
quartiers vous voulez aussi replacer
c'est joseph auxerre de la cacem ça veut
dire quoi
ça veut dire que nous avons des
spécificités nous sommes une ville
rurale
nous sommes la capitale de l'eau à la
martinique mais laisse la spécificité
par exemple par rapport aux anneaux
rivier par rapport à notre nos cultures
par rapport à la protection de
l'environnement
oui saint joseph à des taux des terres
chlordécone y est bien
ce mal qui nous ronge à un avenir
c'est à dire trouver les solutions pour
que demain nous puissions à la fois de
réconcilier avec notre terre et en même
temps faire d'autres positions
à côté des autres de ville de la cacem
nausicaa miasmes je vous remercie
[Musique]